so yeah anyway
blueface and new main go at it
let some of this play i don't know if we
can get struck for this but
oh we we probably can
maybe just i don't want to get [ __ ]
sued by these these pay-per-view
companies are ruthless can we just you
know go to a single frame real quick
you know we can we can leave the video
out like let it or let it play why don't
we play why don't we play it but not put
it up on screen yeah yeah that's people
can just see our reactions yeah and
maybe mute the audio
i mean i watched
uh some portions of it
there it goes
but i mean he got
doinked yeah
he got yeah he got [ __ ] up dude
straight up wobble newman got [ __ ] up
i'm really glad it didn't end up going
bare knuckle i'm genuinely i know for
the kill
that he didn't walk into that
yeah um but he got
he got touched up
and then he got rocked i wonder does he
have like bruises on his face and [ __ ]
oh because he's still filming tick tocks
i don't think so let me let me um
pop over to our boys
instagram oh he deleted his account
do you really oh it's just it's just
called kane now oh
he's trying to rebrand
trying to rebrand
oh he's he's standing yeah no i don't
know i don't see any difference
nah he just
he said it was an honor working with oh
he's still
he's just showing him he's just posting
pictures i think there is right there
pre-training pre-fight
chose the hardest one
most difficult one
did nothing for his career man
except just create a bunch of content of
him getting his head bounced off
some hands
yeah you got touched up
and you know what before anyone goes
you got to respect getting in the rink
no you don't he got paid he got paid no
you don't
that's what the money's for you don't
have to respect that [ __ ] at all
you can respect fighters who get in
there for 30 grand and believe in
themselves and are like i'm gonna become
a world champion one day and you know
you can respect that athleticism you
don't gotta respect this bozo who goes
in there for a quick check and he's like
yes it would or give me a speed
because you know why because cause that
dude doesn't respect you and in a flash
if that kid make a made like
a substantial amount of money off that
fight if you made like a mill off that
fight he'd be
talking so much [ __ ] he'd be on
instagram trying to make you feel bad
yeah i might have got my ass beat but
look at this new rolly i got
nah
nah
preach sorry i didn't dude preach that
dude
sorry i just had to go preach that good
ish dude
no but that's that's true that's
actually true anyone who does this [ __ ]
loves to flex yeah
you know that whole [ __ ] about you know
any of these guys if they lose but they
made a big
chunk of change
they will be sure to remind you that
they're still better than you that's
what they'll try to do
so
by the way did you see the uh social
gloves thing they're suing
uh live nation x or something like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with my camera
um well he said that they're suing live
nation because live nation was the one
that collected people's money
they were like it's live
live it's not even live nation
yeah sorry live x live that's what i
meant what the [ __ ] is live x live
that's a crazy name yo live x live look
at
this
mcbroom's attorney says client is no
longer contesting number of pay-per-view
packages being sold
what does that mean
mcbroom's lawsuit is assigning most of
the blame for the 10 million in losses
uh
uh
is okay
he's they're signing it to live x live
and his team has backed away from their
claim that the events paid numbers were
being misrepresented by live x live
after hiring a quote a leading forensic
auditor to probe livex lives
transactional level payment data from
its payment processors
mcbroom and his attorneys have accepted
livex live's report that only 136 000
pay-per-views were sold
so what
what could they possibly sue for
136 000 that's confirmed now i guess so
wow
no way that's so that's
that's ten times lower than what he was
expecting
more so than that i think he's didn't he
say in in the best or in the bff's
podcast the best friends podcast
didn't they say that in the best friends
forever podcast
um that it was supposed to he was
expecting 1.8 million yeah i might be
wrong but 1.4 1.8 million yeah
and they got 136 000 bro this dude's
life is on fire and he's getting evicted
yeah whoa
damn bro
you should just tell mid dana white
material and just coast man
yeah
yeah take a page out of our book dude
yeah just be mid and coast
just be [ __ ] mid
you know invest in in buying a spaceship
and then
you know
if you're gonna try anything from
[ __ ] friday let it be this one
[Laughter]
that's a direct quote my guy
yeah you didn't even really say anything
right there you just repeated what he
said
exactly and it still works
this is why you can't let people into
the i'm convinced
what goes on in the bonus just has to
stay there
because once you put it out with you
know everyone else is just
passively watching they don't get it man
all our bonus people know when you strap
in at the top of the bone zone it's like
okay this is going to be weird
oh yeah the bone
yeah
we don't need to advertise it that much
but if you know i don't want to say i
don't use that stupid phrase but if you
you know there's no i mean there's
nothing better
if
go ahead yeah keep trying you're aware
you're aware
if you've had this experience just leave
it there if you've previously had this
an experience like this
then you know what to expect
exactly to say to say the very least
no i just i don't think
what i didn't appreciate out of all this
was all with all that yapping
yapping
and they don't even know bro
they don't even know what goes down on
the bonus episodes they don't see you
hanging upside down on a chair
they don't see us three hours deep in
recording slightly delirious
going you know what i'm thinking what
i was so low energy on tuesday my
symptoms started on wednesday
i think i was i was already feeling it
you know what i'm saying oh 100 that's
what i thought well we all got tested
the crazy part is we all got tested and
everyone was negative
how did you guys not get how did not one
of you get sick or kyle said he felt
sick i felt a little ass just a little
felt like a little butt
listen to this hey guys with the last
day of white tik tok getting some
attention from ufc fans did you guys
want us to edit the dana the dana bit
from the latest episode as well or do
would you rather us avoid it
edit that [ __ ]
put that [ __ ] up bro i don't even i just
don't want to deal with it man
why it's funny dude it
who cares i mean you're you're right
you're right yeah yeah we could put it
out it doesn't really matter
yeah
but you know i just i don't i just don't
need like half ufc half nilk fans dming
me on a wednesday being like you
literally look like you are the
definition of a half sender you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i just don't want to deal with it i just
like you know you know you're right [ __ ]
it just put it up who cares it doesn't
matter